hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar reducing complexity and
increasing the value of molecular viral
load STI and Transplant virus testing
with middleware I'm Suzy Valdez of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by Abbott molecular to
learn more visit them at wwe.com so
let's get started before we begin I want
to remind everyone that the event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker Michael such the
senior manager at solution design team
for the Americas for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen Michael you may now begin your
presentation welcome
great thank you Susie I really
appreciate it and thanks everyone for
joining today I'm very excited to be
presenting this topic and it's very
contemporary for what's going on in
molecular my hope today is that you walk
away with a lot more information you had
before that it's for his interest on
your side and that you Spurs also some
action on your side to really bring up
molecular to the next level and it's
testing um the first slide I want to
show you today is really one from the
archives
I think everyone probably recognizes
Geron he was one of the Giants of
quality and he'd written a number of
studies you know based upon inspector
accuracy meaning honor percent
inspection of whatever was taking place
and it began really following World War
two the downside of all this great work
was that he discovered that that kind of
inspection after things have done had to
have completed is really about 87
percent effective and he gave this great
great formula to calculate the accuracy
of an inspector and I won't go into it
but it really brings us to the next
question
you know what is effective inspection
you know from a pure probability
standpoint multiple inspections of data
are indeed effective right we can
determine that where that other person
inspection is about 85% effective and we
can calculate the probability so what I
want to get to is we need to rationalize
and move on in molecular that inspection
really isn't the best way to ensure
quality and so that brings me to our
next set of learning objectives at the
end of this presentation it's my hope
that you understand the role of
middleware in the context of both lab
information systems and the
ever-evolving health educated DHR the
data sharing and reporting process it's
also my objective that you're able to
better compare and contrast between the
functional benefits of adding middleware
to a busy molecular lab and last but not
least it's really about helping you
identify and define a basic validation
plan that satisfies your local
requirements and
a little bit about subsea LSI guidance
it's my belief as a person operating of
intellect of the world that we need to
elevate this inspection process beyond
inspection and to make it much more of a
data driven data decided on a verified
world and I'll show you more about what
that means
from a flow perspective today I think
it's important we examine some of the
history because history tells us where
we are and it gives us a good indication
of where we need to go I'm going to go
over a fairly limited set of definitions
I wish we had a couple of hours and put
in just an hour but I'll give you a
taste of some of the definitions of
words you may not have heard of it
before I also want to talk about the
current status I'm going to build on
some practical examples I want to also
talk about a cost benefit context I'm
going to get you to the point hopefully
where you begin thinking about a needs
assessment and I also want to conclude
with some references to some clsi
guidance that I think would be really
important to people considering tripping
that threshold and implementing
middleware and then I want to conclude
us with a set of question and answers
where hopefully I can shed some
information about our experiences at
abbott molecular
so one of the things I think is really
fascinating this is a graphic that was
created developed by the Joint Economic
Committee it was led by Senator Sam
Brownback of Kansas and Republican Kevin
Brady of Texas they created this
congressional at the screen at the
Congressional Joint Economic Committee
back in 2010 and what this is this is a
diagram of all the relationships that
crisscross between hundreds of
government offices departments and
programs and it's an amazing boxes
circles and triangles and other assorted
shapes it's actually missing a lot of
other parts and pieces so imagine how
complicated it makes it right this is
specifically for Health and Human
Services imagine how complicated it
makes for the 900,000 US physicians
laboratory and other health
professionals this is just describing
the interactions right this is a kind of
a typical government response so the
reason I highlight this is because we
need to get to a simpler interface we
need to get to an approach we're making
data much more digestible for health
professionals now this next slide if
you've ever read this book it's this
report it's really worth getting ahold
of it's a consensus report that was
published by the NEM the National
Academy of Medicine along with a number
of sponsors from teaching institutions
across the u.s. the author's key message
is it's important to take a systematic
approach to address burnout the focus is
on the structure of the organization and
generally the overall culture of health
care you could argue why am i showing
you a report about physicians well I'd
say that it affects all allied health
professionals equally including
laboratorians right the overwhelming
focus on the impact of increasing
complexity and really the need to
improve IT IT related processes and how
information is given to people it's the
backdrop of all this so what is this
pathway leading the molecular I really
got to give you some history and give
some some credibility here because I
want you to see where we came from and
where we are today and this is my
opinion but it really began back in 1966
right with the ad
a program called mumps which stands for
the mass general utility
multi-programming system it's a
programming general-purpose programming
language that provides what they call
atomic consistent isolated and durable
transaction processing now mumps was
developed by two people Neil Pappalardo
and Curt marble in the late 1960s this
hospital used it originally in the
admission cycle and also for laboratory
reporting eventually now the usage of
mumps spread throughout healthcare and
it's actually used as the programming
language for most of the early EMRs
right so it was pretty much adopted to
the 70's and in the early 80s it spread
from healthcare and to financial
and it on eclis it's continued to be
used by some of the same clients today
it's using the electronic health record
systems as well as multiple banking
networks online training so it's it's
got the basics of what makes sense and
it's actually really good in my opinion
the advent of mumps was really the
sentinel event the godess where we are
today with the use of logical programs
in the hospital slab space
so you know I'm still in the history
part right so this path leading the
middle work I've got to give credence to
dr. Jack Layden sin' who ironically is
still on staff at Washington University
Med Center in st. Louis he's a professor
of pathology and immunology he came up
with the idea of one of the first ideas
of applying logic which was the Delta
Jack this is in chemistry right and the
for those of you who don't recognize
this term it's a software logic check
procedure that compares the current
result to the previous result from the
same individual using a specified cutoff
value now that specified cutoff value
represents the maximum allowable change
that is acceptable for whatever the
laboratory procedure is the cutoff value
could be presented as an absolute change
a percent change or rate of change or a
rate of percent change depending on what
analyte we're looking at amazingly
forward thinking for back in 1975 so
think now a dozen or so later years
comes on the scene data innovations and
you can read their full story they came
on the scene in 1989 with a focus on the
laboratory versus the EMR it's a great
company that continues to evolve and
improve connectivity and insights but
this is where it began right folks back
in the 70s and 80s and they were the
first true system to connect and really
begin managing discrete instrument data
from within the laboratory
almost done with history but bear with
me a second this is the actual excerpt
from dr. Jack Layton sand I thought it
was really timely I wanted to show you
that in 1975 someone was thinking about
how they use technology and IT to
actually catch errors in laboratory data
amazingly forward-thinking
so a little bit more history albeit it's
my interpretation right it's a fairly
recent event to have middleware in the
traditional chemistry immuno chemistry
your analysis etc world it's perhaps
even more new to molecular and I'm
showing you in this picture what were
three distinct yet isolated instrument
tools using the cleanse in the 1970s the
smack or the sequential multiple
analyzer that was used for high volume
chemistry's the ACA or the pouch
chemistry from DuPont that was used for
discrete chemistry's and then a general
use spectrophotometer from Milton Roy
okay so and that's about history my
intention is that you start seeing more
of the analogy between where chemistry
was and is today and where molecular
viral load STI and Transplant is headed
so let's move on now to the future so I
think it's important to level set on
some acronyms the hospital information
system or H is is is often the term used
to describe all the elements of a
patient record the electronic health
record of a patient is updated with all
that testing information so whereas the
EHRs is kind of a more real-time patient
centered documentation it's really there
to make sure that the health info is
available instantly and it's really
securely captured to authorized users
whenever they need it EHR systems are
built to share data between health care
providers organizations laboratories
specialized experts imaging facilities
pharmacy schools etc you know an average
electronic health care record contains
and it continues to grow
demographics history statistics
treatment plans allergies immunization
dates radiology vital signs in addition
to lab an administrative building
so what has advanced at the hospital
level there's a proliferation of
specialized systems to make sense of and
categorize digital images and other
discrete pieces of information that H is
can't sort out or isn't capable of
rendering into useful information not
likewise you have the lis in the same
situation the lab information system the
lis alone really isn't capable of many
of the facets of information management
categorization and reporting so I may
draw some criticism for that statement
but it's why middleware is popular and
gaining popularity in the laboratory so
let's finally turn our attention away
from all the history and anecdotes and
talk specifically about middleware
so what is middleware it's basically
software that sits on a high capacity PC
and that could be cloud-based as well it
has the physical and logical connection
abilities the various lab instruments
that are capable of communicating by one
or more protocols whether that serial
tunneling or whether that's using the
more up-to-date standard hl7 protocols
it's a middleware it's helping them make
sense of a whole lot of discrete
information and it does so by employing
some set of rules or rules engine that
governs the disposition or the next
steps or the transformation of that
discrete testing information now
oftentimes it's modular right and that
depends on the vendor right it could be
include things like sample tracking
extended quality control charting and
providing access to review by other open
data sources and a whole lot more this
all depends on the vendor but all these
additional modules are all capable and
resident in various systems out there
commercially available so I wanted to
make sure that we kind of demystify the
middleware is nothing more than another
computer system with rules and modules
that govern and give more granular
control to lab information right this
sort of summarizes it as well right it's
the middleware is any number and type of
extraction and amplification instruments
discrete standalone all working
independently but interface
bi-directionally where possible and what
that's going to look for you as a user
and this is meant to be an exhaustive
it's really a proportional to your
imagination because the contemporary
middleware systems out there are really
capable of almost any kind of data
merging and extraction but it's really
meant to provide a single point of
management for results both results that
are discrete or Kamel results it's meant
to give you multiple instrument status
in one single console it's meant to give
complete centralized maintenance records
from all the instruments that might be
interface it's real strong ability is to
create what I call composite results and
looking at data longitudinally over time
and space
look at trends and things and be more
prognostic it also allows obviously
rules development and enables auto
verification which we're going to spend
a little bit of time on and other
quality checks but it really is only
limited by your imagination and
programming expertise it's nothing more
than a way of managing discrete data and
categorizing it in a way that makes
sense for your laboratory well what I
want to focus on to some common rules
and the one that's probably most
familiar to most people in the audience
today is Auto verification ad or Auto
verification like I said it's probably
the most common rule and a rules engine
applying Auto verification rules can
remove the need for what I consider to
be rote human inspection of results I'm
not discrediting the result inspection
but this advent of of having people
review or having two people review data
is really not contemporary for example
all negative serology results coming off
an imino an amino acid Eliezer or all
electrolytes that are in the normal
range those are typically automatically
Auto verified in today's chemistry world
because there are control set in place
there are value check set in place where
as a human Ed's NOAA X traditional value
human inspection in the molecular
laboratory usually via paper printouts
has been the norm but it's been
automated via middleware rules they can
automatically apply validation criteria
verification criteria and render a
judgment some folks in the audience are
probably nodding their head they're
already doing this that's my
understanding the vast majority of
people have not even begun to apply Auto
verification because they've never been
exposed to it we can learn a lot in the
world of chemistry
I want to turn your attention to some
limited definitions that I've put on
screen and it's my understanding that my
presentation along with these
definitions will be available after for
you to reference so I won't read through
them all but here's some common
definitions that maybe someone four into
some of you but it really comes down to
the idea of applying program logic right
Auto verification I'll read this rule is
a rules based decision process using
computer rules to verify the lab result
it's going to look at all the indicators
as far as quality control to make sure
the result is valid now a lot of this is
set up by the user in conjunction with
help from one of the more of the
commercial vendors but it's probably the
most powerful tool you have to release
results more early and to free up those
resources that might otherwise be doing
100 percent inspection the rest of
definitions are self standing I won't
bother to read them but I wanted to make
sure you had a limited set at least it
referred to as we go forward
I like to refer to all this as the
iceberg of possibilities we're so much
accustomed to looking at test results
right the iceberg represents the
potential and there's currently a number
of things that are visible I show above
the surface right but the future is
relatively unlimited but it's a
progression right especially for
molecular labs where some needs are not
fully understood or fully realized there
are a number of things middle work and
accomplished commercial systems have
those modules that describe and add-ons
to achieve a variety of influence that
really are probably otherwise impossible
to achieve or really probably rely too
much on people resources that frankly
most of us labs don't have so focusing
on our verification is probably the most
easiest one to tackle but there are lots
of patterns that can be looked at there
are prognostic tools that can be applied
to this it's all really proportional to
your imagination so I wanted this to
share with you a few potential rules to
consider right and these are coming from
my experience and traveling around the
Americas an excellent source of
inspiration or unmet needs could really
include the physician community that you
service here's just a partial list of
what I've come up with and some that
I've seen implemented in various
countries and jurisdictions and what
they intend to accomplish in a molecular
lab setting for example in the situation
of where a viral load and a genotype are
ordered at the same time it's possible
to automate the cancellation of the
genotype if the viral load is
undetectable sounds pretty pedestrian
right but it's actually something can be
easily implemented whereas otherwise
it's probably relying on a human to
remember to go cancel the viral cancel a
genotyping because it's no longer
necessary for a viral load is
undetectable another example is if a
dilution is required for a sample that's
above the upper limit of detection
automatically hold that result automate
some suitable message to the lis or
clinician and automatically order a
retest that's a little bit more
sophisticated that's the idea of
combining what are normally steps that
are followed by SOP by
person and having the system automate
the transaction
one I think is powerful that for a
positive STI automatically retrieve the
past test results and combine into a
single report this can all be done in
middleware if the previous result was
completed in whatever day window whether
it might be actually picking up residual
DNA again these are all attempts at
stewardship at better management and in
my opinion some of these are being done
manually where they could be done
automated by programming exercises into
a rules engine in middleware so this is
all about supporting and proving the
human element looking for what I call
defects aliens which is stuff that may
be occurring that you don't see it's
about supporting combination reporting
of taking two discrete pieces of
information and joining them together
for physicians benefit it's about
looking at trends and reporting in a
different way by looking back at data
and across your enterprise and it's also
supporting what I air-quote as better
interpretation but I put the infinity
symbol there because it really is only
limited by what your thoughts are now
here's a few more to consider as well
automatically ordering an HIV genotype
if the viral load is ordered and
positive capturing serology results
generate a composite result right
serology should kick off the process but
you know it's all about combining and
this is actually from a customer example
I have where they called it test and
treat so they give results otherwise
maybe relegated the physician to go
gather himself or herself put it in a
composite report
another one is if high-grade viremia 4bk
virus is detected Auto order a second
urine sample within two weeks and this
is following a specific manufacturers
package inserts if the two consecutive
urine samples show high-grade viral
present Auto order when it's considered
to be the next appropriate sample which
is a whole blood or plasma sample not a
urine so automating those processes
again that might otherwise be governed
by SFP can be driven by and rules based
kind of approach probably the most
common one I see out there is the last
one I've shown the list around sample
unit conversion or changing values
automatically for different physicians
who want to consume either log or other
values differently so those are just a
few of the items I wanted to talk about
it really is limited talking to any one
of your commercial vendors who have
middleware solutions we'll give you many
more ideas the implementations really
when they're done correctly should
result in a dramatic reduction in
paperwork in the review time that we all
normally do it should dramatically
increase your turnaround time by my
estimates on average an average run of a
viral load testing let's say it's around
50 samples probably has about 20 minutes
of paperwork review and I'm not saying
it's discounted and not valuable but
there are ways to automate that to
recover much of that time to remove the
human element
you're also less dependent on staff an
attendant miss and skill level I've been
in several institutions where the
primary operator is gone someone else is
less field has to operate and you in
that situation they probably experience
a little bit of a lessening of the
service level again
the whole idea is and to replace people
because we're the ones that drive the
process but let's automate things that
are more rote and routine and and let
the skilled experienced people focus in
on more of the special cause issues and
things that really require much more
thought it also in my opinion and we've
yet to demonstrate that but I'm working
to demonstrate it is it offers better
adherence desks of P and process
definitions automating things that are
normally relegated to a human being who
can forget can get distracted by phone
calls that's what it's all about at the
end of the day it's about more results
released with a higher confidence of
their validity
so I promise I talked a little bit about
some of the clsi guidelines don't fault
me the last time these were updated was
about 15 years ago but in reviewing them
they're still very very much on point
for setting the stage for not only
managing the validation point framework
but also giving you insights as a new
user about which frameworks you consider
in planning the testing process so both
auto AOA and Auto Ted a both are worth
purchasing they really go over even
though they're a little bit dated they
go over really all the test cases around
stress and boundary that should be
included as you verify and validate your
middleware implementation it's pretty
straightforward these are the backbone
to documents that are out there that
really govern and give an idea and
certainly the vendors of these systems
are well aware and can help you with
putting together a really good
validation program but these are two of
the guidelines I think is probably the
most specific and offer the most
specific guidance and use the
nomenclature and verbage and approach
that any inspector would want to see
one other thing I wanted to bring to
your attention there's growing and still
expanding audience of organizations out
there that are trying to evolve this
whole process of communications and data
analysis the IBD industry consortium
connectivity or ICCC is a global it's a
nonprofit organization that's really
dedicated to creating and encouraging
all this unified connectivity standard
because not every system out there is is
functioning the same it's all about
reducing the cost and their variability
of the data exchange between the IVD
devices and healthcare informatics and
the Klingons because we're not there yet
the the law the laboratory and litical
workflow profile and all these are
available by the way on the internet
really addresses that exchange of
information related to patient and the
QC test orders and the results between
systems and health informatics because
it's it's evolving folks obviously I
think we all know that it's not there
yet the purpose of a law profile really
is to improve interoperability between
IBD testing systems and those
informatics systems and most all of our
contemporary vendors out there that are
producing chemistry or molecular systems
have adopted the law profile but not
fully so you need to be aware of that
just bring it up because I want you to
understand their groups and
organizations both of these offer
insights and opportunities for you to
increase your knowledge so I wanted to
bring your attention to them
so in summary you really can't automate
confident release of the molecular viral
load STI s and Transplant testing it
doesn't need to be a it isn't a hundred
percent by applying 100 percent
inspection even applying two or three
people mathematically doesn't get you to
100% I'm not saying we're releasing poor
results I'm saying that if you really
want to achieve perfection you've got to
automate it with something that doesn't
get fatigue it's going to provide
confident results faster
now you can trigger events you can be as
conservative as you want for meeting
some of this it's really limitless you
can Institute Delta checks you can
reproach this gradually write middleware
an introduction into molecular is really
a progression it's not meant to replace
everything anything but the advent of
random access testing from vendors and
quick result being generated and
automated process control being much
more evident on the instruments to me
speaks clearly to the need that we need
to be able to release those result
confidently as they're made available
and not not be stuck in our batch
mentality and there are multiple
middleware vendors out there to compare
and contrast a lot of the lis vendors
and now getting in more into the space
as well and they're bringing their own
solutions you know data innovations is
what I've mentioned already I'm sure a
lot of us have familiarity with them
there were the pioneers other sources
exist out there as well I encourage you
to to talk to DI and others because
there's lots of opportunity for four
different decisions to be made so I want
to end with a couple of comments to
write the rule writing doesn't have to
be complex it can evolve over time some
of the rules can be really sophisticated
if you study what's done in a mythology
or your analysis those are meant there
to be learned from and perhaps
extrapolated from but you don't have to
start off with everything those things
being automated like I said the sources
for V and B support both of dry tests
and the wet tests that you'll need to
conduct are available from the clsi from
vendor and there's a host of other
online resources out there
new directives for interoperability
getting us away from the old serial
standards and getting us into hl7 are
all available when the advent of them is
out there online so hopefully today I
left you with at least an understanding
of where history has taken us where the
future can lie and some glimpse into
some of the resources that might take
molecular the next level when it comes
to data management and writing reports
and using rules engines
so Susie I'll turn it back over to you
thank you so much Michael for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started and take a look at
some of our questions coming in now
Michael our first question from an
audience member is what are the vendor
options that are available other than
data innovations
oh great Crescent Susie you know I
didn't want it to be a commercial
because Abbott have a system as well
it's called a light IQ AMS and it's a
middleware version that's meant to
operate agnostically across the spectrum
and it can work with molecular as well
as chemistry urinalysis et cetera so my
own company has their own solution as
well but di is one there are other
variations out there like I said
available from Cerner done quest and
Medi tech I don't have a quick access to
their names but each one of those lis
players has middleware like options that
can be employed in the molecular space
as well thank you for that and our next
question is actually a two-part question
Michael is it practical to just add
middleware to molecular or should I talk
to the other lab departments about
piggybacking on to their agreement with
their current middleware vendor wow
that's a good question yeah I mean
there's no doubt that most every
contemporary Glenn lab out there that
has a molecular lab as well is probably
employing some version of middleware so
you know my suggestion is that don't
reinvent the wheel
talk to your clinic an ER parts figure
out what they've been doing how they've
automated because it could save you
money and time on licensing it could
also save you some resources as far as
the validation approach because
realistically molecular testing although
complex is not necessarily any more
complex in its review than a lot of
sophisticated chemistry amino chemistry
tests as well so you know if you can
piggyback onto a data innovations
already existing install you know that's
the better way to do it it might save
you hardware and software and garner
more support so yeah definitely talk to
your Clinton lab counterparts I found
that oftentimes molecular labs are
physically and logically isolated but I
don't know why that is I just think
there's opportunity to encourage people
to talk to the Quinns lab counterparts
and say hey what are you guys doing with
advancing your control and management of
data how can I be a part of that
thank you Michael and these are great
questions coming in our next audience
number wants to know what is the
approximate cost and are there
reoccurring fees it depends yeah no it's
all about what you want to do right so
as I mentioned in the presentation
vendors have different levels of access
and support they have different modules
that made it modular for a reason
because they want people to pick ala
carte what they need I would say the
approximate cost to get started with a
basic installation is probably including
hardware is probably in the twenty
twenty-five thousand dollar range
now that doesn't include some of the
consulting time you might need and what
they call syncline connections and a
host of other things that you know the
vendors are much more able to explain to
you you know there is that's about the
threshold to start doing it and I know
they also have cost models to
demonstrate you know where you're going
to get recovery so I'd encourage you to
look at that I like anything there's
there's a lot of recurring not a lot
there is recurring fees for support for
telephone support and as you advance
your your skillset knowledge and you
program more rules
there's recurring fees that are
associated with that as well to consult
with the vendor and they're pretty
nominal but it's something you should
account for thank you and we have time
for a couple more questions there's a
great question great who writes the
rules you spoke about and does it
require a degree in computer science so
um the rules are generally constructed
as a joint project between the vendor of
the system and someone has identified in
the laboratory who really understands
the process it doesn't really require a
computer science degree some of them do
have what I call scripting language
which you need to get a little bit
familiar with but it's in my opinion
it's not any more sophisticated than
programming a formula in Excel so you
don't have to have a degree in computer
science maybe you did back in the 80s
but that's for in 2020 it's not required
great thank you we have time for one
more question and this audience member
asks your example rules are interesting
who creates the rules and what is the
typical governance process for
maintaining editing and creating new or
revised rules wow these are great
questions um so the rules are generally
as a result of an unmet need or an
aspirational leader within the
laboratory a good way to start is
looking at who is actually looking at
data today and what are they doing with
it and in my experience some
institutions are looking to actually
plot demographics and understanding
where there's incidence changes or
prevalence changes especially around
sexually transmitted disease so starting
there will help give an idea of what can
be kind of automated and pulled into a
report it doesn't require a human the
governance process is typically multi
fold it's usually someone in the core
laboratory but also someone who
represents the quality function and
someone who typically in the case of STI
s is generally someone who is checking
epidemiology or other areas um typically
what happens is there's a meeting that
gets convened on a quarterly basis when
there's new rules promulgated or
promoted for review by pathology and the
people that I just mentioned and then
the process goes that there's a dry test
portion usually in an off environment
and then there's a wet test portion
where they actually run samples as part
of the validation and then once that
activity is completed the rules are in
place and staff is updated and you run
and roll
thank you so much Michael and you have
any final comments for our audience
members um my only comment is is to
think about your process holistically I
know a lot of laboratories around the
Americas at least have multiple discrete
systems and you've got multiple
operators doing individual things just
think about the power of being able to
combine that especially in the advent of
today's more contemporary systems that
do all this testing that release results
every hour every frequency get out of
the event batch mode mentality you don't
need to be there think about the
implications and the value to the
patient and the provider if you're able
to release results active a lot earlier
what interventions or what data or what
decisions can be made even if it's a
couple of hours that might benefit the
patient so don't be afraid is my thing
challenge the vendors encourage them to
get involved with your solution set and
that you know get as much information as
you can to make a good decision I think
the time is now to consider and do this
Michael thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
I'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Abbott molecular for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go I'd like to thank the
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on dance
demand period will be addressed by the
speaker via contact information you
provided at the time of registration the
webcast can be viewed on-demand and
labret swil alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share this email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time bye bye